excusez-moi ouais une telle voiture sur quoi ouais
JJ ouais ouais combien d'argent dans le mien Oh
soixante-douze mille le mois dernier tu
me montres un talon de paye pour soixante-douze mille
dollars dessus J'ai quitté mon travail maintenant
et je travaille pour toi hey écoute  J'ai démissionné
ouais je vais dans les actions je m'appelle
Jordan Belfort à l'âge de 22 ans je me suis
dirigé vers le seul endroit qui correspondait à mes
hautes ambitions nom du jeu
déplacer l'argent de la poche de vos clients
et avez-vous été  poche mais si vous pouvez
faire de l'argent aux clients en même temps, c'est
avantageux tout le monde a raison non j'ai
créé ma propre entreprise à partir d'un
atelier de carrosserie abandonné, nous ne viserons pas à
être le 1% des Américains les plus riches J'aime
trois choses J'aime mon pays  J'aime
Jésus-Christ et j'aime faire
attendre les gens
mais j'avais besoin de les modeler à mon
image avec ce script Je vais apprendre à
chacun d'entre vous à être la meilleure
entreprise du monde Je devenais une légende n'est-ce
pas  Tu es marié ouais mais beaucoup de
gens ne peuvent pas lui faire des amis  n ennemi je
gagnais tellement d'argent je ne savais pas quoi
en faire 26 000 $ pour un dîner papa
nous ne sommes
plus pauvres  travailler là
-bas c'est Russ pourquoi ils étaient chers pourquoi
allez-vous ventre
la vraie question est que tout cela n'était
absolument pas légal
et vous avez sur le chou aide de
tout votre entourage est fou c'est bon
mais mon temple tu vas bien ça
ici c'est le pays des opportunités
tu viens d'essayer de soudoyer un
officier fédéral c'est l'Amérique c'est ma maison
bien pour toi le spectacle continue ils
vont devoir envoyer la garde nationale
prends moi parce que je ne sais
pas non  Je ne travaille pas pour toi mec ouais mon argent
prends l'oie techniquement tu travailles pour
moi